hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Deadpool spider-man video just
because Tim Miller was making a bunch of
announcements about Deadpool - they
confirm cable they also talked about
trying to get spider-man to crossover
with Deadpool if you're not familiar
with Spidey pool that's actually a
relatively recent development deadpool
and spiderman have run into each other
since the late 90s so I'm going to
explain their history in the comics then
I'll explain how Spidey pool is a little
bit different from that in how a
Deadpool spider-man crossover might work
them appearing on screen together is way
further off but I'll explain what's
going on so just to start with Deadpool
to confirm Fox has two premiere dates
that they booked for the next year ones
for October 6 2017 the others for
January 12 2018 so the thought is is
that one of those will go to Deadpool 2
now they had a lot of success with the
February release which typically isn't a
big time for movies but it was a
Valentine's Day movie so it's kind of a
special case so I totally think that
they could do a January Deadpool movie
that's successful but typically you see
comic book movies like Deadpool big
tentpole movies falling in the spring
the summer in the holiday season so it
remains to be seen I think it just
depends on how fast they move through
production on the new movie they've
already started writing it it's the
exact same creative team so if you like
the energy of the first Deadpool movie
it's going to be a lot like that only
they will be getting cable which is
really awesome I'll have some links in
the description I did a bunch of
Deadpool in cable videos when the
Deadpool movie came out but what's all
this business about Tim Miller talking
spider-man so he's mostly talking
tongue-in-cheek like hey if Marvel and
Sony can come to an arrangement then
we're going to do everything we can to
get deadpool and spiderman on screen
together - now realistically i think
what's going to happen is is that all
the big studios are watching Marvel and
Sony work together and they're going to
wait to see how successful the new
spider-man film is because the thought
is is that by sharing the character with
Marvel who is hugely successful right
now their movies are doing amazingly
well if general audiences like the non
fanboy crowd totally buys into the idea
of Spider Man jumping between his own
movie at a different studio in the
Marvel movies than the other Studios
like Fox with its x-men franchise will
be a little more open to sharing
characters the Deadpool movie was so
financially successful though that I
don't think that Fox is too worried
about crossovers or anything like that
they're like okay we'll put Deadpool
cable in a movie people will love it
it'll do great so there's just a lot of
financial and political things that go
into sharing characters between studios
but that doesn't mean that it won't
happen
I think if everything goes well with the
new Sony spider-man films then
definitely within the next 10 years you
will see more sharing of characters
between studios but history of Spidey
pool so deadpool and spiderman have
crossed over many many times in the
comics the term Spidey pool is a
relatively recent thing though their
first technical crossover came in 1997
so it was a long time ago but it's kind
of timey wimey so listen to this
Deadpool and blind Alec gets sent back
in time to amazing spider-man number 47
which is from the 1960s so already
you're a little confused
it's Deadpool from modern day getting
sent back in time to a spider-man comic
that was made in the 1960s so even
though the issue was released in 1997
they drew it page for page like it
looked back in the 1960s in the actual
story was amazing spider-man number 47
spider-man fought a couple of his
notable villains like Kraven Norman
Osborn what Deadpool does is that
because he's get sent back in time he
uses this image inducer so that he looks
like Peter Parker and he fights Norman
Osborn and Kraven very minimal
interaction between deadpool and
spiderman himself
so yes it's a crossover but it's a
really meta crossover and it's not
Spidey pool yet their next big crossover
was more of a straight-up crossover
where they're meeting each other in
modern day that was in 2000 Deadpool
almost destroys the Marvel Universe by
causing this giant invasion in all these
Marvel hero teams have to get together
to stop it he winds up interacting with
spider-man the story itself is kind of
weird because they tell it in this
momento way where the beginning of the
comic picks up really late in the actual
story in the beginning of the story
isn't told to the end of the comic if
you've never seen the movie memento it's
Christopher Nolan early Christopher
Nolan is really cool it's really trippy
next big crossover kind of meta it
happened in the exiled comic in 2002 so
what happens is is a bunch of different
characters from different realities get
thrown together in a team deadpool and
spiderman become team mates so they're
actually working together for one of the
first times even though they're not
super best friends or anything like that
but it's not really canon yet because
the versions of their characters in this
comic are from different realities like
it's a version of Peter Parker bonded to
the carnage
symbiotes Deadpool's a little bit
different too so it's pretty weird you
can kind of see a theme developing with
them throwing these two characters and
comics together but making it really
weird meta so the next big time they met
up was in cable and Deadpool number 15
also very weird cable goes missing from
the main reality so Deadpool tries to
track him down by hopping through the
multiverse so he's traveling through
different versions of Earth on one of
them he runs into apocalypses four
horsemen he finds cable but cable is now
the horseman of war in spider-man ends
up being pestilence it says I mean it's
a really fun idea but we still haven't
got to the point where they're super
best friends in the main 6-1-6 universe
in case you don't know the 6-1-6
universe is like the main universe so
anytime you read a character that's not
from the 6-1-6 universe it's not canon
to the main comics the first real
spider-man deadpool crossover was until
cable and Deadpool number 24 wherein the
main universe in present-day Deadpool is
going after a Daily Bugle reporter that
just happens to be with spider-man
so spider-man tries to stop him they're
kind of going up against each other the
next big time they met up Deadpool was
actually helping spider-man they were a
little bit friendlier but it was
happening in the Ultimates universe
it was ultimate spider-man number 91
through 94 and they have a bit of a
team-up but because this is before
Secret Wars it's not happening in the
main universe slowly approaching Spidey
pool in 2008 deadpool ends up bringing a
bunch of dinosaurs into modern day and
it just happens to be during the middle
of a symbiote outbreak so that's how you
get two symbiote dinosaurs so just total
comic book moment you don't get more
comic book than symbiote dinosaurs
spider-man's totally pissed at Deadpool
but they have to work together to clean
up the mess
Deadpool suicide Kings was a great team
up where Deadpool gets framed for a
crime a bunch of Heroes come after him
but eventually he's able to convince
spider-man that he didn't do it so they
have to work together to take the real
villains down here's a really funny meta
crossover avenging spider-man number 12
and 13
Deadpool enters spider-man's mind
inception style and has this grand
inception like adventure as you can tell
it was a big riff on the movie Inception
it was written after Inception came out
like inside spider-man's my Deadpool
goes back to his days at Midtown high
school and kills a bunch of bullies that
are bullying spider-man
and we finally get to the birth of
Spidey pull Deadpool annual number two
this was in 2014 so relatively recent
Deadpool has to take down chameleon in
in order to fool him he borrows the
costume of a knocked out spider-man so
thus we witness the birth of Spidey pool
so if you're confused about what Spidey
pool is it's Deadpool as spider-man it's
a team-up comic but it's really where
Deadpool starts to become spider-man
because the really meta Easter egg is
that when Rob Liefeld was pitching the
Deadpool character originally to Marvel
editors he'll be like Spider Man with
swords and guns with great power and
zero responsibility now you guys have
may have heard about Spider Man and
Deadpool the actual comic that wasn't
released till January of this year
literally at the beginning of the year
spider-man and Deadpool
got their own title together I've read
the first couple of issues is pretty
good it's a lot better than gwenpool way
better than gwenpool so if you're big
fan of Deadpool spider-man together you
could totally check it out but here's my
big question for you guys
let me know in the comments what is your
favorite deadpool and spiderman moment
from the comics and if they do appear in
a movie together how do you want that to
play out like what kind of story do you
want that to be do you want it to be
more of a spider-man story like a
straight-up movie or do you want it to
be more of a Deadpool story where they
break the fourth wall it gets super meta
and they make fun of the entire Marvel
Universe now what's gonna happen next is
that there's already been a whole bunch
of other big comic-book news like Ben
Affleck is writing directing and
starring in the next Batman solo film we
kind of knew that was going to happen so
it's not a huge surprise but Warner
Brothers just confirmed it there's new
flash video I'm working on Jonah Hex is
coming to legends of tomorrow there's
just a couple big things I'll be doing
videos for next and I also saw some
really cool Black Panther vs. Winter
Soldier footage that I might do a video
for why you guys wait for that next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the spider-man movie
homecoming I'm starting to think the
villain is going to be Ezekiel but I'll
talk about that in my next spider-man
video and you can click here to watch
the Doctor Strange teaser again thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you